- Juhu! Ja!
- Was ist denn los?
- Alles in Ordnung?
- Wisst ihr, wer vor euch steht?
- Ähm …
Ein Mann, der blöde Fragen stellt?
- Der Mann mit dem besten Abschluss
im gesamten Jahrgang.
- Nein?
- Gratuliere! Schön!
- Das ist ja toll!
- Ja. Tja, das bedeutet, ein Ende
meines Studiengangs ist in Sicht.
- Dein Studium ist erst beendet,
wenn du deine Studiengebühren
abbezahlt hast.
- Tja, wenn ich erst mal arbeite,
wird das kein Problem.
Könnt ihr euch an die Fotos erinnern,
die ich für die Zeitschrift gemacht hab?
Die Berufsportraits?
Die Redakteurin hat mir schon
einen Job angeboten.
- Krass!
- Und nimmst du ihn an?
- Ich weiß noch nicht.
Dann wär' ich ja angestellt …
- Und du willst dich lieber
selbständig machen?
- Schon …
- Was bedeutet „selbständig“ machen?
- Wenn ich selbstständig arbeite,
dann bin ich mein eigener Chef.
- Und ich kann entscheiden,
welche Aufträge ich annehme
und welche nicht.
- Aber es kann auch sein,
dass du gar keine Aufträge bekommst.
- Hehe. So wie bei Pepe … Hm?
- Tja, das ist eben 'n bisschen
unsicher, ja.
Aber das muss ich ja jetzt
nicht entscheiden!
Später!
- Cheese!